[Music]
i'm told that the best podcasts are true
crime podcasts so this is my true crime
episode
david middleman is the founder of othram
a company that has completely reinvented
how to evaluate dna
they are solving cold cases left and
right
identifying unidentified victims and
catching criminals that have been
getting away with their crimes sometimes
for decades
his stories are absolutely riveting i
now know why true crime podcasts are the
most popular
this
is a bit of optimism
david thanks so much for taking the time
i really appreciate it just so people
know what you do
can you share
a cold case that your team has cracked
so that we really get a sense of what
how special
your work is i'll tell you uh one story
that comes to mind there was a girl she
was a 17 year old high school
cheerleader her name was carla walker
this was a 1974 and she was coming back
from a valentine's day dance in february
and she was going to high school in fort
worth texas
and she leaves the dance with her
boyfriend in his vehicle they end up
parking behind a bowling alley
you know doing what high school kids do
and then out of the blue according to
the boyfriend some guy just comes out of
the darkness pulls open the door uh
yanks her out of the car and and that's
it he never sees her again but the time
is just such a wild story it's like you
know who is this guy he didn't know who
he was just randomly out of the blue
comes out and uh grabs the girl and runs
and um and she was found unfortunately
brutally beaten raped and murdered not
long after just a few days after uh in a
culvert and
the law enforcement in the area worked
the case to the best they could uh
looked at lots of folks talked to
everyone obviously her school friends
known associates everybody and and the
case just didn't go anywhere they
couldn't they couldn't figure who it was
and so this case ended up sitting
ultimately for 46 years until we got
involved and through the course of of
the investigation the coda system which
is our national system run by the fbi to
catalog dna profiles from primes that
kind of came into prominence in the mid
90s and in the early 2000s they started
looking at a whole lot of cases in new
ways and going back to see if they could
develop these dna profiles time to
people and so they continued to work
this case it wasn't just sitting they
worked the case continuously right
before we got involved there's a guy
paul holes and he was an investigator in
california he helped track down the
golden state killer using some of these
newer dna techniques and he was doing a
tv show for nbc and it was called the
dna of murder and he was profiling 10
cases that are these really kind of
bizarre cold cases that never got solved
going back to revisit them to see if
there was insight he could glean from
the investigation and if ultimately dna
testing or something could help and one
of those cases it was this case of carla
walker and they actually found a dna
profile that was from the crime scene in
which carla walker was murdered and they
uploaded it to codis there was no match
they used it to rule out a number of
folks that thought might be involved i
mean obviously they test the boyfriend's
dna anyone that knows her everyone's
excluded they've got this unknown male
profile and they can't figure out who it
is and so anyways fast forwarding a
little bit further it's april of 2020
the show airs and i like paul hold so i
i i can't resist i see episode nine all
the cases kind of spoke to me but it's
episode nine's in fort worth texas is
three hours from our office and the
story ends with a black title card that
says dna testing is in progress who
knows what we'll find but it's like an
unfinished story so i call paul and i'm
like come on man you got to tell me what
happens at the end and he says well i'm
really sorry we ended up sending it out
and they couldn't even build the kind of
profile you would need to do some of
these more newer advanced methods so it
looks like the case will remain cold i
said
you know that
it can't be like i would like a chance
to look at the case uh could you please
introduce me and so anyways long story
short um he introduces me to the fort
worth police department detective leo
wagner and jeff bennett they tell me
they've fully consumed they didn't just
fail but they had fully consumed
the dna that they had available to them
there was another extract that had much
less dna and was much worse quality but
it wasn't suitable for any testing and i
said i'll take it i'll take whatever you
got and so they deliver this dna to us
uh sometime in may and my lab director
is looking at the data you know he knows
that this is a high impact case and
they've been asking about it they're so
nervous and he's like i'll just take a
peek and as he takes a peek he sees
connections at the genealogy side and
the family records side and he's like i
actually think i know what the answer is
so he pulls an all-nighter we're looking
at the information it's july 4th it was
a saturday um early in the morning i'm
at the gym and my director calls me and
he's like i have i think i have the
answer and i'm like if you have the
answer let's call law enforcement and
the thing you got to know about these
detectives it's like nobody goes to cold
case unless they really care about cases
a lot of cold case detectives will spend
the entire cold case career you know
solving no cases or even one case and i
remember jeff bennett he had told me
he's like i just want to solve this one
case before i retire so anyways i was
like i don't care if it's july 4th they
got to call the guy so i call him on
saturday morning he's still in bed and
he's like hello and i'm like i'm like
jeff i have some news so i get my lab
director on the phone and we start to
tell them about what we had found and
and we don't we told them about the
family we identified we start discussing
a surname and there's these three
brothers that we think could be involved
we don't even get past a surname just
like hang on a second i can hear him
ruffling pages because i think he like
sleeps with the case file and he's like
could it be this guy we talk about
anyways turns out what they had not told
us is that when the crime had happened
um the guy when he pulled the door open
he had knocked out uh he had knocked
unconscious the boyfriend with the with
the bottom of a gun and the magazine uh
discharged it fell onto the ground and
it was actually the gun was not
recovered but the magazine was so they
had a pretty good idea of what weapon
was used in the crime and they actually
had done kind of like a
a request for anyone that had a gun like
that or purchased one in the near time
in that area and there's like probably
100 people that have bought a gun but
guess what one of the guys that had
bought it was this guy that we ended up
uh identifying so he recognized the name
he's like that guy's on my list and so
now with this new information they go
back to their group they end up doing a
tremendous amount of investigative work
after we did our part because we don't
solve the case we just provide leads we
just provide information and so they go
back and they test the dna from this guy
and he matches a crime scene not using
our technology but just using standard
codas because kodus is really good at
confirming identity it can tell you that
you were at a crime scene it's not good
at finding someone so if you're not in
the database it won't find you it can
just confirm once you're there that
you're the person so it confirms that
he's a guy they arrest him and he
confesses and while he's in prison he
does a radio interview and confesses
again and tells the radio host that it
was an accident
something between it was an accident and
she brought it upon herself because
apparently from his perspective they
were they were bickering he rescued her
then he got the wrong idea um and
anyways she ended up dead it's actually
not uncommon to blame the victim when
something like this happens and um and
then and then out of the blue because
the case has to have one more twist
ending he unconfesses and he says his
confession was converse so it's a whole
another year
until uh the fall of 2021 when we go to
trial ultimately he decides to once
again confess and so the case is closed
he's convicted in not
[Music]
of the story is available going forward
it is unnecessary for a few people to
wait 46 years to identify the suspect in
a crime or to identify someone there's a
lot of unidentified persons people that
have died some of them the victims of
crimes it's like how do you how do you
solve a crime if you don't even know who
the victim is and so these people remain
unidentified forever for decades yeah
and and it doesn't have to happen
anymore the guy who was the brother of
carla walker his name is jim he's a
wonderful fellow he dedicated his life
to this case he's the one that made so
much noise about the case that he got
this tv show picked up he lived in the
same house for 46 years and he told me
he didn't want to move because he was
hoping that one day a police officer or
detective would come to his door and say
here's who killed your sister you know
the world kind of moves on when
something like this happens but these
families are frozen in time they cannot
move forward they're they're
destroyed by the tragedy there's no path
forward because they don't get an answer
i can't think of a more crueler fate and
it was an amazing thing to be able to
see jim walker in court able to address
the person responsible there's no way to
bring back his sister carla but like to
the extent that you could give someone
the opportunity to face the accused and
have that discussion express himself
like it happened and um he was very
gracious and family members from both
sides
of both families have come together
since then and it's it's really quite
touching i mean it's it's it's insane if
you're not in this field it's insane to
see how many people's lives are actually
affected by a single crime there's
obviously the victim in the family but
there's friends associates the family
members of those that do commit the
crimes but aren't really responsible
like none of these people knew that he
had done this so anyways it's a
wonderful story and i think it captures
the magic that we're trying to to scale
to to every family that's been uh
tortured by a crime and not just one it
is amazing i'm bubbling with questions
what technology
did you advance like what is it about
your lab that was able to solve this
case where all the others who had tried
and did the dna work were unable to come
to the same conclusion so there's
there's a few things that we do
differently codis was developed by the
fbi the way the system works is that if
if there's a crime that's committed and
they recover dna from the crime scene or
if you died and they don't know who you
are they can develop a profile and the
profile is basically a set of dna
markers you know there's a lot of spots
in your dna and the dna letter at that
spot could vary and so if you take a
number of markers you can get a profile
and codis started out kind of small so i
think it was like eight markers now it's
like 20 markers but there's these 20
markers in your dna
and the information at these markers
varies from person to person
sufficiently that the odds of you and i
having the same information at all 20
markers is essentially you know in the
quadrillion you need more people on
earth than exist to be able to have the
chance of finding another person right
that information so that's what makes
coda so powerful it's like a very
straightforward way you can sample a few
positions 20 positions and it's been the
mainstay for the last 30 years it really
transformed
forensic investigations in the late 80s
the biggest issue with codis is that
kodus was designed to track repeated
crimes so you commit a crime you're
convicted of that crime they know who
you are they log you so if you ever
commit another crime or you already have
they can connect the dots and say well
hang on this guy's responsible and
particularly for like across state kind
of situations right you commit a crime
in florida now you're in california
there's a national system that ties it
together so you can't hide by jumping
from state to state
codus works perfectly for what it was
intended to do which is to track the
criminal behavior of known people that
commit crimes but here's the thing let's
say you know someone's walking in the
woods and and someone murders them and
there's no identification on the body
that's not something codis was designed
to tackle and so the problem is because
kodos is really the only real dna tool
that's been around for the last 30 years
they just use it for everything and so
they're they're going to be situations
where codis is not the appropriate
solution or rather they use codis and it
doesn't return an answer and they're
like well i did what i could the second
thing is that codis has certain uh
requirements as all testing does you
know you need a certain certain quality
of dna certain parameters to make it
work so
to answer your question you're asking
what makes other different other is
different for a couple reasons number
one we can access information from dna
that's been considered essentially
unusable too degraded too low quantity
right dna that like literally can't be
used in any other test so even if the
person was in codus you'll never know
because there's not enough dna we worked
a sex assault in las vegas from the
equivalent of about 15 cells worth of
dna like i mean there is no laboratory
that would accept it they try trust me
number two instead of 20 markers we're
collecting tens of thousands to hundreds
of thousands of markers so we're
collecting a lot more information and we
can learn a lot more about that crime
scene and what that allows us to do
ultimately is to access the
biogeographical origins of somebody and
the other thing we can do is we can do
long-range relationship testing and we
can you know if for an unidentified
remains we can find the next of kin in a
case like carla walker's case we can we
can trace through public records and
family trees and sort through and figure
out who who the person responsible was
how did you find yourself on this path
in the first place i started working in
this space forensics is newer to me i
started working the space during the
human genome project and i got really
fired up about this initial effort the
human genome project was this effort to
figure out essentially what all the all
the dna letters of a human being are
and the idea is if you could build this
kind of map of all the letters you could
then use that to do to do research
improve health you learn so much from
understanding what the dna sequence of a
person is and so i worked in the human
genome project in the 90s and then my
first company helped bring a lot of this
like kind of newer version of dna
sequencing and testing into the clinic
10 years ago this stuff wasn't used in
medicine and now it's you know you can
get a dna test for whatever you want on
any street corner but here's the thing
it was it was a few years ago it's 2018
when we realized you can get a dna test
on any street corner to learn about a
medical condition but what street corner
do you go on to solve a crime and and so
there were some early ideas for how to
tackle this problem um i proposed some
ideas i actually proposed some ideas to
some folks um in the government to see
if we can get funding and they were like
it sounds great how much does it cost
and i was like should be no more than
like 20 or 30 000 a case they started
laughing at me and they're like that's
that's ridiculous so what happened is
over the last 10 years i kind of just
doubled down on diagnostics and
developing technology and what's
happened is the um the cost of doing a
lot of this testing just like computers
cost goes down power goes up it's not
just me by the way it's like it's a team
of 25 folks and so we all have tackled
different aspects of this problem from a
medical and research perspective and
we're like how cool would it be if we
can make the world a better place with a
different a different use of dna testing
basically and um ended up being a lot
harder than we thought it would be but
it's been really exciting because for
any one case that you provide even the
smallest amount of value for there are
so many people that benefit on the other
end of it and so it's just it's just
exhilarating and it's why we get up in
the morning i mean it's super exciting
to be able to come and do that right we
worked a case in canada this was a case
the guy was found in a septic sync after
he was brutally murdered and for 40
years they couldn't figure out who he
was and they actually said he's never
going to be identified they spent a
million canadian dollars on this case
like a million canadian dollars
and and we solved the case for around
5000 us
you can imagine the skeletal remains of
this person were not in pristine shape
sitting in a septic tank and everything
else that had happened to it and we took
these human remains and we were able to
get usable dna we were able to build a
profile we were able to find a next of
kin turns out he had a living sister we
eventually tracked her down case solved
after and i'm telling you they've done
so much work dental analysis facial
reconstructions like who is this guy
they were like he's probably not even
canadian maybe he was passing through
like i mean it's a weird case right like
no one knows who he is so they just
figured he couldn't have been from the
area but he was he was he was there and
he had a name and he was waiting to be
identified by the way one more thing
sorry please
i'm a little passionate about this
in las vegas where i told you we were
working a number of crimes we identified
a man that's never been accused of any
crime that had actually been the uh the
rapist and murderer of this girl and as
soon as we did that they went back and
were able to match his profile and kodus
to a few other crimes that we have
nothing to do with so that's another
thing you should be aware of is like
when you're working a crime
sometimes you pay one time for one case
we actually solve a handful of cases
they're now looking at him for as many
as five other cases but when i visited
your website i was astonished that it's
not just police that can give you a lead
people can submit
their leads to you directly you know can
you help me find my my lost sibling i
found that so astonishing that you put
yourself out there you put your lab out
there to say how can we help you to all
of these people who may have lost
somebody you know recently or a long
time ago i really love the engagement we
have to work for law enforcement they're
our customer they're the custodians of
the evidence but it does not mean that
we can't
provide transparency to the crowd and to
engage the crowd to help us and you know
sometimes a crowd has suggestions for
cases sometimes they have tips sometimes
they want to share their dna profile
because it might be the stepping stone
they're not gonna be closely related but
they could be distantly related and be
the stepping stone to an identity
sometimes they help us fund cases we
we've literally crowdfunded cases
for agencies that can't unlock federal
funding yet or are still working through
the grant process and i gotta tell you
like what i love about those cases and
what makes me most proud is you've
probably never heard of most of those
cases some of them are only a few years
old so they're not even cases that
you're going to see on a they're never
going to become cold cases these cases
get resolved now almost in real time
like we have that's the other thing to
note is we do cold cases we do a lot of
contemporary cases too and these cases
are not famous cases so these are cases
that without funding and without the
notoriety may never get solved i mean i
can't think of any time in my lifetime i
don't know if you can in your lifetime
like when in our lifetime could the
crowd basically direct the activity of a
cold case investigation it's wild like
if you stop to think about it it's like
mind-blowing so i love the technology i
love the dna testing i love solving
crimes and helping agencies get answers
but like i even love even more the idea
that like this is a community endeavor
it was a lady that was murdered and
found in the storage unit in in durham
north carolina and and the case went
cold they couldn't figure out how it is
and there was enough random people on
the internet that were like i want to
know who she she is it's been enough
years it's time for her to go home they
literally crowdfunded this and they went
to the agency and were like look it
doesn't cost you a dime let's go let's
go knock out the case and the thing you
should know about these agencies is like
again like there's no cold case
detective that's like i don't want to
solve a crime they all want to solve
crimes but they're they're hamstrung by
having too much uh to do too little
resources so you come to them and you're
like look i'll do this testing and
generate the leads at no cost to you the
crowd funded this
they're in so we do it and we ended up
identifying her and getting her back to
family so that's that's a pretty wild
thing like with a little bit of
participation from the crowd you can
take cases that otherwise would have
just sat in a box forever and just get
them sorted out i think that's probably
the most exciting thing about our
business is there a favorite case you
have that when you look at one project
that you worked on that you're like this
this summarizes the reason why i'm doing
this work this is the most
satisfying case i've ever worked on i
hope they could all be like this one so
here in texas we have a girl that was
known as the walker county jane doe she
was a kid and she's literally the poster
child for unidentified jane does and
she'd been unidentified again for like
40 years since i believe the early 80s
she was found brutally murdered and
sexually assaulted in huntsville um like
after halloween night it's terrible
again no leaves his body was found on
the side of the highway and and they
don't even know who she is so how are
they supposed to figure out who did this
turf they don't know who she is there
was just so many hurdles the case was
old the skeletal remains was generally a
good source of dna
didn't work
so there was just nothing that could be
done they tried all sorts of dna testing
you know we tried working with the bones
and we couldn't figure it out and we
ended up again it's just like there's
enough people that care the national
center for missing exploited children
they're partners with us so we start
working with them other people are
getting involved next thing you know it
we find out there was an autopsy there
was this like little piece of material
that was preserved during the autopsy
they applied this process to preserve it
and preserving uh tissue during an
autopsy is a great way to be able to
look at the tissue later but it destroys
dna but it's all we have left so we take
it we literally invent a new method we
had to develop a new method to be able
to read this kind of like broken up dna
and in the end we're able to get just
enough dna
to where we can read and build a profile
and the crazy thing is it was very easy
to find the relative once we had the
profile that the challenge was that most
of the evidence was was just unusable
and it took it took such a tremendous
team effort from so many different
agencies and dedicated law enforcement
non-profits and others just to find the
thing we needed and and then in the end
a name i mean i just love how every
other agency if you'd given them this
dna sample this preserved piece of
tissue they'd say yeah it's unusable
sorry
and you guys invented an entirely new
technology
simply to read the dna it's like leave
no case behind is kind of our motto so
every time we encounter something new we
try to develop if we if we don't have
methods methods to access it because it
essentially it it builds up our toolkit
um because again like i don't want to go
solve like the 10 most exciting cases i
want to get every case solved and so to
do that we really have to be
sensitive to the fact that there are
such a wide diversity of inputs it's
like
trust me every time i think i've seen
everything that comes in from a crime
scene there's something else so we once
had to work on a piece of material
the agency called us they're like we
have we have bloody gauze i'm like oh
that's great blood no problem well it
comes to us it's like bloody gods from
40 years ago so it's basically dust
we're like what do we do with this and
so you just never know what you're going
to get but um what happened in that case
we were able to get dna from it so
by the way our success rate i'm not i'm
not here to tell you our successor is
100
but we are very conservative if we
haven't done enough cases where we feel
we've had similar types of dna and good
outcomes we'll actually reject the case
and put it in our backlog and we've had
cases that we've had to reject in 19 and
20 that we've then gone on to help law
enforcement solve in 21.
that case i told you in vegas with the
15 cells worth of dna i would have never
taken that case in 2020. but what's
happened is we've just continuously used
less and less dna and we worked enough
cases with low dna i tell them like look
this is risky it's lower amount of dna
than anyone's used but it's a calculated
risk because we've done other things
that are similar so yeah i mean we're
we're very conservative we're in no rush
but at the same time we don't want to
leave any case behind right so we either
try to develop a method or just goes on
our backlog on our waiting list until we
feel
like we can take a calculated risk to do
it right so you said policing agencies
usually come to you as a last resort
shouldn't they come to you first
i don't want to be pushy i they don't
have to come to us first but i'd love to
be like the second or third call instead
of the 50th call so because the problem
is when you're the 50th call you know
you usually have no dna left or it's in
very bad shape i got to tell you another
quick story if you want to hear it
there's a number of cases where they'll
have skeletal remains and they hire an
anthropologist to do like analysis of
the bones and they can look at the bones
and the markers on the scalp and other
parts of the skeleton and they can tell
you this is a man this is a woman they
try to guess is this a person who's
white is this a person who's asian could
it be a person that's african right they
do the best they can do but especially
like with partial skeletons they're
really imprecise so we had a case
actually like a week ago out of michigan
in the report it's like this body was
hit by a car dropped out of a high
altitude or like you know this person
was beaten to death it was a terrible
condition of these remains
and when they did the assessment of of
ancestry they had a whole bunch of
guesses you know he might be black he
might be white he might be biracial it
could be a whole bunch of things right
but when we did the dna testing it turns
out he wasn't he was asian
he was east asian
and then when we look at some of the
records it turns out the investigators
are looking to see like is there an
east asian person missing and there's a
guy who was a grad student in michigan
who um had told his wife he's he's going
to end his life grad school was a pain
and he didn't want to you know he was
under too much pressure and he jumped
out of an airplane allegedly is the
story and they found the plane crashed
in canada but there was no body
anthropology would have never led them
to the answer because they had the wrong
biogeographical origins but once we
figured out that the guy was east asian
it begged the question could this be the
guy they test a relative it was the guy
they had found him what are the
implications of this technology outside
of the work that you're already doing
like flash forward a decade or two what
kind of things will this open the door
to do you think i think we're going to
drive a repeat crime probably to
extinction i think if you leave dna
somewhere you're going to get caught and
you're probably not going to rape or
murder another person i think there'll
be other kinds of cases that will
resolve i mean we still in today's day
and age have these cases of baby does
right so babies that are discarded by
parents that don't want the baby
and don't want to take it to a church or
a fire station or somewhere else and
just like literally discard the kid
those cases are hard to solve because
obviously that baby baby's not in codis
and it doesn't have a license or any
identifying documentation but like with
dna testing these cases will resolve
almost always so crimes that have been
traditionally inaccessible serial
predators that that you know prey on
others repeatedly and leave dna they'll
get caught the first or second time
instead of the fifth time the idea of
having a cold case you know like
unidentified person i think that'll
largely become a thing of the past i
think eventually this technology becomes
a deterrent for crime and that's i guess
what i was alluding to
with respect to cases involving you know
the murder of a little baby or something
else is like eventually if you get
enough of these cases worked at scale um
people begin to think twice so maybe
right now we're helping family after
family then it moves towards doing this
at scale to to clear backlogs and
reconnect people uh at scale and then
eventually works as a deterrent to keep
society safe because if you want to do
something terrible you'll find something
else to do because harming people in a
violent way and leaving dna will no
longer be something you can do more than
once or twice without getting caught
what an astonishing thought right what a
science fictiony kind of thought that
violent crime is something you can
perpetuate once maybe twice at most and
that's it
uh it's it's kind of an incredible uh
premise for a film if you think about it
yeah it sounds science fictiony but i
think it's science fact in the very near
future if you leave dna somewhere you
will be found and and you will not leave
dna again david you are endlessly
fascinating your work is endlessly
fascinating i wish you nothing but good
luck and good fortune if you want to
learn more about david and his work or
if you'd like to actually find a cold
case that you want to sponsor or promote
visit
dnasolves.com d-n-a-s-o-l-v-e-s
dot com david
thank you again such a pleasure
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then
take care of yourself
take care of each other
you